Oh
The Little Mermaid Ariel beginning okay
it kind of be interesting I mean the
animation looks pretty good and maybe we
could see the backstory of some of these
characters maybe we can see earth alone
how she got where she was and the
interaction with the sisters and the
father and the mother okay this could be
interesting
it starts off showing Ariel and her
sisters with her mother and father and
suddenly this pirate ship comes out of
nowhere okay and apparently killed some
other in a very awkwardly done edit
seriously can just cut the black this is
really weirdly done but okay let's keep
going so the father is so discouraged by
the death of his wife in the fact that
she loved music so much they decided to
outlaw music throughout the kingdom oh
it's this stupid thing yeah the story
that you've heard a million times it
probably started with Footloose and yeah
was even really good when they did it
then and like that you know every single
damn thing that's gonna happen everybody
said they all want to sing but they
can't sing so Ariel goes and tries to
find out where she can sing but that
conflicts with the father and they get
angry at each other and he's not really
bad he just doesn't see what's really
important and they're gonna butt heads
and then some stupid last-minute villain
is going to come in try to screw
everything up oh god no surprises
nothing new even have two songs you've
heard before they're just sore reworked
versions of famous conga songs in fact
how do they know the song shake senora
if they live underwater then that's not
one even be recorded yes okay I'm
pricing to be hard about that but
nevertheless this is not a very good
movie it's not all full per se I mean it
definitely has awful moments in it but
again you can definitely get an idea
that they're trying to put something
decent together I mean the pacings not
that bad it will take moments to be
quiet and sort of let the emotion sink
in they do try to give the sisters
personalities but there are six of them
so it's kind of hard to remember which
ones which and like I said before the
animation is damn impressive I mean okay
we're not going to see a grand landscape
in this or anything but just
get the linework look at the expression
look at how flowing and elegant it is
for a direct-to-dvd movie help just for
an animated Disney movie in general it's
really really nicely drawn it's also
interesting to see a movie where not
only the main characters are
good-looking I mean you know how this
works it's usually the male and the
female and they look really pretty or
handsome and everyone else is supposed
to look cartoony and over the top here
the sisters are in a lot of the film and
they're all drawn beautiful so it's kind
of interesting just seeing these really
good-looking characters throughout the
entire thing it isn't just the main lead
they allow for some nice expressions and
flowing movements and it's like it's a
really really nicely drawn but that
doesn't excuse the fact this is just a
dumb story with dumb writing there's
this villain played by Sally Field who's
kind of a servant of the king looks
after the girls and sort of wants to be
the second-in-command what's in a while
she'll get a laugh and he Sally Field
can be very funny but to answer the
question that everybody is thinking
including myself no it's not Ursula the
wait a minute in the first film she
describes herself that she used to be in
the palace and then she did these evil
things and she was thrown out that's
exactly what this character does and
even kind of looked like a younger
skinnier version I mean why why wasn't
the nurse alot she even had cure eels
ago after the heroes it was so obviously
meant to be Ursula I was waiting the
whole time to see some sort of magic
zapped her she was transformed or
something or they give her a new name
like Ursula is actually a demeaning Dame
and that's what you'll be called now or
something but no it's just a completely
different character that has Ursula's
backstory come on you guys Sally Field
play a young earth what we want have
minded so yeah the movies free stupid it
makes no sense I guess if you just have
little kids that want to see it just to
see nice music and Ariel swimming around
looking pretty it's fine for that it's
not like viewing the Beast 3 or Mulan to
where there's arguably bad stuff for
kids in it I mean it's harmless but it's
also mindless nothing in it is original
every line every plot thread you can
point to a million other movies that
have not only done it but have done it
better
I guess it's fine if you just want to
track your kids for an hour and a half
but anyone looking for the magic of the
original this one dead in the water
[Music]
you